Elections in Bosnia and Herzegovina are undemocratic
and stoke ethnic divisions.
That's according to the European Court of Human Rights,
which ruled that the country is an ethnocracy
and the ethnic representation
is more relevant to its political system
than things like economic or social issues.
The case was brought by Slavan Kovetschowicz,
a political scientist,
an advisor to a member of the presidency,
who claimed he couldn't vote for
anyone genuinely representing his political views.
He argued that this was due to the political privileges
given to three ethnic groups Bosnaks,
Croats and Serbs
under the constitution.
Essentially,
only people from these three groups can be elected to
the presidency
or the house of peoples,
which is one of the chambers
of the Parliamentary Assembly.
He also blame the country's territorial rules,
which basically mean you can only vote
for people belonging to one of the three groups
according to where you live.
The ECHR agreed,
ruling that these territorial
and ethnic requirements are discriminatory.
The judgment has caught the attention of the EU,
which Bosnia and Herzegovina wants to join.
The European Commission said that
if the country wants to open accession negotiations,
it needs to bring in reforms
to make sure there's Equality for all citizens.